Thomas Alva Edison boy
trust you brought your checkbooks so
[Music]
full of ideas it will take me 12
lifetimes to execute it I'm working on
something now something so new the world
will never be the same I'm George
Westinghouse medicines new electric
system is significantly cheaper than gas
does that keep you up at night there's
always more to see we are gonna be big
Edison says he's months away from
lighting up the world stoves washing
machine lecture carriages I could do the
same thing with electricity that I do
with gas Westinghouse Electric Company
Edison Electric it has to be
vultures in every venture gotta keep him
away this is what he thinks of you don't
let a magic 8 you this is how he is
sawing Westinghouse Electric shall
endure it's a parasite
his current kills people only because
you said it was mr. Edison if you say
something about me or my company again I
would ask that you tell the truth
Automation transportation communication
that the man that controls that cart
controls that future
though he may be unfamiliar to you his
studies have demonstrated an
understanding of electrical matters
unlike anyone I have ever known
gentlemen and lady Nikola Tesla so
what's your trade I fix problems
radiance
you